hi everyone my name is
olson lee and i'm a product manager
within the google cloud working on key
management and encryption
along with me i have my colleague joseph
valente who is the product manager for
the key access justification and we're
here to talk to you about the new world
of controlling your data in the cloud
with ekm and kj so in this session today
we're going to talk about some of the
innovations
from the google cloud platform that's
going to help you really have tight
control over your data in the cloud
to an unprecedented degree and by the
end of this presentation you'll
understand
how the system works and how it's going
to benefit you and hopefully some of you
will actually
give it a try as well and understand how
you can actually use it to protect your
most sensitive data
so in this talk we'll have three primary
sections
first we'll talk about the current
encryption that's in gcp
and then followed by a more of an
in-depth discussion around cloud
external key manager
and then after that i'll turn off to
joseph who's going to talk a little bit
more
about the key access justification
product with you to start off with let's
talk about the current encryption gcp
and usually i like to start off with
this this scale that defines the control
of the keys and the products that we
have available
on the left hand side we have the
situation where google has
control of complete control over the
keys on the right hand side
it's a situation where google has or the
customer has control over the keys
so to start off with on the left hand
side we're talking about default
encryption
and this is this is basically google's
um
capability of encrypting all your data
at rest when whatever it is in whichever
service
so whenever you bring data up into a
cloud it's always encrypted and there's
no way to turn that off
and this was google was the first cloud
to do this
and then for people who need a little
bit more control we introduced cloud kms
and cloud kms provides a global service
that provides
management for your software keys and
then
cloud kms performs two primary services
one
it'll allow you to actually do
encryption decryption and signing
for whatever blocks of data that you
provide through easy
easy to use rest api and two
it allows you to integrate with other
services such as bigquery
gc gcs cloud sql
et cetera that allows you to take the
the data that's encrypting those
services and ultimately control it
through a key that you control in cloud
kms
now beside that we have cloud hsm which
is basically the
the hardware version of cloud kms and in
cloud hsn
you can actually create keys and perform
all crypto operations
within the fleet of of hsn's that google
maintains
and these hsn's are all fips 140-2 level
3 devices
one of the nice properties about print
keys in hsn
is that the hardware will actually
actually make sure that the key material
is never exposed
including to google itself next to that
we have customer supply encryption keys
which is one of our first
technologies for key management it's it
was tailor made for
for gcs and gce and essentially in this
situation
the data arrest is protected by a key
that the application has to provide
every time it tries to access the data
itself now it's fairly limited and you
also have to come to terms with the fact
that the application has to perform some
of the key management
and also has access to the keys and it
it will
probably won't be expanded beyond gcs
and gce for those reasons
and then finally we have a new entry
which is the private host hsm
and this is an offering by which if you
have your own hsm device
that you would like google to host in a
cola that's nearby one of our data
centers
because you have workloads for example
lift and shift workloads
then this is available for select
customers and
it's something that you know you can
talk to me or talk to
one of our sales reps and get more
information about
but even with those offerings we're
still left with the problem
how do i retain possession and control
over my keys while i'm still trying to
take advantage of the cloud for
processing and storage of my data itself
so
you have the cloud with all its immense
computing
capabilities and scale but you still
want to have that tight control over the
data itself through control over the
keys what do you do
so wouldn't it be nice if you actually
had something beyond the offerings the
five offerings that we have listed here
something that perhaps goes to the far
right of the scale
and that's where cloud external key
manager fits in
the service is now available as ga in
all regions around the world including
multi-regions
and the service is is
the first time that cloud is able to
allow you to separate your
your data fully from your keys and allow
you to essentially externalize
your keys outside the cloud some people
including now unless you're calling this
hold your own key compared to
you know bring your own keys but
essentially it's that
and so if we start talking a little bit
more about cloud extern
cloud external key manager you'll come
to see quickly what i'm talking about
but before we go into that let's
backtrack a little bit and i want to
talk a little bit about customer
management encryption keys and how
how the keys hierarchy is essentially
set up
so in this diagram here you'll see the
fact that when you bring
data up into the cloud let's say it's
it's a gcs object
you're gonna what we'll do first of all
so take that object we'll split it into
separate chunks
okay we'll take into manageable chunks
and each of those chunks will have its
own individual key
generated for its aes key and
once the key key is generated it'll
encrypt that piece of data
and the these chunks of data will be
replicated and then
basically distribute across all the
servers within our data centers
now you can't obviously put that key
right next to the data itself
you need to actually make sure that key
is protected so you encrypt it or wrap
it
using some other key so you encrypt it
with a key encryption key
so to speak and typically what customers
will do is that they will use a key
that's in our cloud kms or cloud hsn
to actually be the key encryption key
for that data they have in gcs
or a number of different services as
well
now in the cli index cloud external key
manager
we have a situation where you follow
that same pattern except that instead of
having a
protecting with a key encryption key
that's in our kms or hsn that key
actually resides outside
and so if you see the diagram here a
user can actually go in
and either put their data through in
bigquery
and compute engine or if they want to
actually directly encrypt the data
through through a symmetric key that's
external they can do that as well
and these services communicate directly
with our kms our kms
recognizes the fact that these keys are
not internal that they're external and
then
parlays a request out to our cloud ekm
service which then communicates with the
external key manager
and so in in the example i gave earlier
with gcs
the the data encryption key is sent to
kms or hsn
to actually do encryption decryption
wrap and unwrap
in this example the daily encryption
keys will be sent to the external key
manager which would do the wrapping arm
wrap and send it back to us through a
secure channel
now the key point here is that that
external key
that's doing the wrap and unwrap is
always outside
it's strictly outside of google and
google does not have
a copy or access to that key itself so
as you can see there's a clear boundary
now between the data and the keys
the keys themselves which provides you
with that ideal kind of security
separation
now uh in terms of the the integrators
that
have support for cloud ecan there's five
currently half of them
are cloud services another half are
providing infrastructure services
so in terms of cloud services equinix
ionix and talus
they all provide cloud services so you
can sign up using their
their web portal create a key and it's
basically a key that they'll
manage for you in the cloud and another
half are are providing things like hsn
so for tanks and talus both provide hsms
that you can
host in your own data center or on
premise and unbound cell
software that that you install into your
own
servers and you perform multiplayer
computation
but then the question becomes why would
i go through this and what are the real
benefits of external key manager if
they're not obvious already
so number one maintain key problems
comes to mind right away
and what i mean by that is that you'll
have a situation now where you
as the the person who owns the actual
external key manager
will have the will will have really
really
strong tight knowledge around you know
where the key was generated
uh where it's kept who has access who
may copy
and you'll have your own set of audit
logs that keep track of all the usages
and these are all things that would make
your compliance regulator very happy and
make it very easy to articulate to them
the where the key is and the fact that
you have ownership of it
key access control is another really big
motivator for people to use cloud ekm
so as i've been explaining in the
previous slides
the keys to actually decrypted data
arrest are always outside
okay so from that perspective
if that key was ever withheld then
there's no path
by which google can actually go and
decrypt the data
so once the data is at rest it would
stay at rest effect it becomes crypto
shred at that point
until the external key key is made
available again
and then the third reason is centralized
key management and so
in many cases there are situations where
a customer may want to have one
centralized key manager where they can
implement
one set of policies for all their keys
in their
in their company and this may include
keys are in the cloud
in other clouds on premise and this
gives you a really really nice way of
actually managing
and keeping the keys all in one place
and so hybrid cloud
multi-cloud you know single policy these
are all
reasons why you might may want to use
cloud ekm
now in terms of configuring the service
it's very very easy
so in the diagram that you see on the
right hand side this is just basically
our ui
for creating a key so typically you've
seen the fact that you can generate a
key
you can import a key but now you'll see
that there's a external manage key
radio button if you select that then
what happens is that once you create the
key externally
you'll be given a uri that will
basically define that key
and then you you come to our dashboard
uh our ui
and select externally manage key and
then you enter at the very bottom of
that page you can see the key uri
field you put that in there you click
create
and from that point forward will
validate that the key exists externally
and that the key and then from that
point forward the key will
show up as if it's any other key within
kms
now it'll look it'll look identical
except for the fact that if you
list the keys out under protection level
it'll say external rather than
software or hardware okay um a couple
other things to point out about this
this is only available currently for
symmetra keys
and um again it's something that
is available in all regions so that's
that's a nice thing
now there's a few considerations that
i'd like you to take away when you
actually use this as well
um first of all these things are outside
of google infrastructure
so as a result there's additional points
of failure there introduced as a result
of this
and if it's a situation where this is
really
a big concern for you where you need to
have something that has a high degree of
availability high degree of
performance low latency all that stuff
and you want to make sure that
something that you know has cloud scale
for example
then it may be something that's worth
considering to use cloud kms or cloud
hsm instead
right uh in general i actually usually
recommend to my customers
to you know think of things very
holistically that when you have data
then you should be able to categorize
data in terms of
at least the most critical the you know
high importance and maybe less
importance
and based on that that should drive the
type of key management
management selection that you make with
ekm perhaps being used for your most
critical data
now errors that come from the external
key manager for example there's a
network error or the external key
managers
is turned off for whatever reason then
these are all going to be manifested
when you actually try to use the key
itself
you'll get very clear errors that say
that the key manager is not accessible
the key has been disabled uh things like
that
and the errors themselves will show up
as user errors
and you know they'll either show up
through directly through the error
message or and they'll also be logged as
well
um so if you turn on data access logging
you'll see them in your logs
now there's only one uri per key as you
saw in the previous slide
and the implication of that is that in
that you need to be in control of
the availability of the external key
manager yourself
and so yeah in that case you may have to
do something like you know
[Music]
leverage vips or leverage things like
load balancers on your side
to make sure that you have a properly
available system uh
you know that that's making your keys
available for your production workloads
and please uh work very closely with
your external key manager provider
uh as they should be able to provide you
with guidance around the best approach
in terms of
choosing locations how to set up your
system to make sure that's highly
available
[Music]
now i'd like to show you a quick demo of
how we use
our cloud ekm together with ionic to
protect data and bigquery
and so in this demo you'll see real
quickly how powerful cloud ekm
can be in protecting your data in the
cloud so the first thing that we're
going to do is create a new key
and so as i explained before you have
three options you can
use a generated key meaning that the key
will be created by google
either in our cloud hsm or cloud kms
service
or you can actually use key import so
that you can provide your own
key material or the third one is
externally match key which is what we're
interested in
and i'm going to select the external
match key and you can give it any
name that you like and as you can see
the purpose and the key type
are grayed out because the only type of
key that cloud ecamm supports at the
moment
are our symmetric keys
so at the very bottom there's a field
called the key uri
and this is the only other thing that
you have to provide when you create the
key and external key manager they'll
provide you with
this uri which uniquely identifies a key
and in this case i've already created a
key in ionic machine
and so i'm just going to paste in here
and then hit create
so just like that the key has been
created and what's happened under the
back
underneath the covers is that not only
have we cataloged that key within our
cloud kms
but we've actually gone through and
validated and tested that key to make
sure that it exists
so now i'm going to move over to
bigquery so
you can easily go and create um
your own data set or
your your your table and
you can um associate it with that key by
simply going to advanced options
saying customer manage key and then
choosing your key
if it doesn't show up you can just
simply you know enter the key id
directly and just put it in here but
i've already done this to save some time
and as you can see here when i actually
run you the results that comes back
it's nothing really interesting but this
data
in order to be able to be decrypted and
then the query run
actually went externally to ionic to
get the the data encryption key
decrypted and they came back so that we
can decrypt the data and show you the
result set
now to prove that this is actually what
happened i'm going to go to
ionic's dashboard and i'm going to
disable this
key that i just that i've associated
with the bigquery data set
so now that that's been disabled let me
go back to bigquery and try running that
exact same query again
and so you can see that we return to
error right away
and the error message says external key
provider message so the message came
directly from
the ekm that state that the operation
was denied
and so this is basically a message
that's coming directly from the external
key manager
stating that the key was denied and
therefore because we couldn't use
external key to actually um unwrap the
data encryption key and therefore we
couldn't actually run the query
so the the from our perspective from
google's perspective
the data is no longer accessible now to
re-enable that all we simply have to do
is just re-enable this
key policy and i just did so right now
and i go back and i hit run for the same
query again
and now the data is available again so
this is
sort of a quick demonstration to show
how tightly linked
the the ability to actually decrypt the
data and run
uh run the the query is to the key
that's external
so now that you've seen how easy and
powerful
using cloud ekm is with bigquery and
it's the same with gce as well
i'd like to turn over to joseph who's
going to talk about key access
justification and you'll see how the two
together
will take it to the next level in terms
of control of your data in the cloud
thanks elsa as also i mentioned i'm
joseph valente the product manager for
key access justifications here at google
cloud
and i'm really excited to talk to you
about this new product and why we think
it's a huge innovation
i'm going to give an overview of how
this product works and hopefully talk
through
why it's such a huge benefit to you if
you're using external key manager on gcp
and as part of this walkthrough i want
you to imagine that you're a person
who's using bigquery today
and you're just using the standard
default encryption with google
and you go ahead and run a query and the
bigquery software needs to
decrypt your data because it's encrypted
by default and so
it's going to go ahead and call our
internal key management system and say
please decrypt this data for me so i can
run the query
the internal key management system will
go ahead and authorize that decryption
the bigquery software will will perform
the query
and then we're done
if you want more control though over
this process you may want to
instead of using the default encryption
as illsung discussed earlier in the
presentation
have more control by using our cloud kms
service or our cloud key management
service
this key management service allows you
to control the keys yourself
and if you delete one of these keys then
there's no longer any ability for the
service to access your data
even when you're using this though there
remains two pathways that
are often of concern to customers who
are using the absolute most sensitive
operations on gcp and those are the
administrators
who continue to need who are still
needed to run the bigquery software
as well as the key management service
we obviously lock down administrative
access very very very tightly
there's only a very small number of
people who are able to exercise
administrative privileges
the things that they can do are very
very limited you can also use
tools like our access approval tool to
put yourself in the approval loop for
this
for these kinds of administrative
operations but the concern
that is there in the most very very
sensitive cases
is often too much for people and so they
would prefer to not have the
concern at all and that's where our
external key management service comes in
once you use the cloud external key
manager service to host your keys
our key manager administrators no longer
have access to
the key encryption key as ilson was
discussing before which is now
living inside your key manager your
external key manager service
obviously that comes with a set of
trade-offs you need to continue
working with your partner to manage the
availability of this key and
to make sure that you're meeting your
goals in that in that space
but the trade-off in some limited cases
is obviously worthwhile
um for these operations and so if you're
using the key manager service you get
this new benefit
but there's one piece missing which is
that requests are coming into the
external key manager service
and you need to still have visibility
over why those are happening
they can happen for three reasons you
are running a query
the bigquery software itself is
performing some operation
like it's doing a compression or a you
know data optimization
uh so that you can run your queries more
efficiently later
or there's some administrative operation
happening so you've opened up for
example a ticket with google and you've
said i'm
experiencing some performance issues and
i need you to go ahead and take a look
at something and tell me what's going on
and what key access justifications gives
you is it gives you visibility over each
of these reasons
through a justification that comes
through with every request that is made
to your external key manager service
what we're now going to see is how you
can use blocking policy
on these requests when each request
comes through you can set a policy at
your external key manager that contains
any combination of sort of allow or deny
rules that you want
you can say for example block all access
and
the key will become completely
unavailable and google will have no
access to your data whatsoever
you can block uh just the administrator
uh rows that are the three the four
green rows at the bottom here
and that will stop google administrators
from having access to your data
even though um you know you'll still be
able to continue using
customer initiated or system operations
to continue using your service
and what this gives you is the ability
to become the ultimate arbiter of access
to your data
you are the person who is the ultimate
decider of
when your data can be accessed and for
what reason it can be accessed
so what we're excited to announce today
is that key access justifications is now
in beta for google compute engine
persistent disk and bigquery
covering the transition from data at
rest to data in use
and this the exciting part about this
software is that when you use it
together with external key manager you
can become the ultimate arbiter of
access to your data
and this works together with the
integrity commitments that are contained
in our privacy website as well so you
know that google doesn't have
any kind of backdoor access or other
ways of getting access to your data
it really works the way it's described
we need to come to you
and query you your external key manager
to decrypt your data
and we give you a reason when that
description happens that you can use to
determine whether or not to grant us
access
what does this mean for you you become
the ultimate arbiter of access to your
data
no other cloud provider is offering you
this level of control
your keys are going to live outside
google with no administrative access
and you'll have visibility over why
those keys are accessed
with the ability to deny google's access
for any reason
so the fine print can you turn this on
yourself
not right now we have a blog post that
you can head to which has a link on it
where you can
put your uh express your interest and
we'll be in touch with you
and consider whether you're eligible
based on a variety of criteria
you will need to use google's external
key manager products to use key access
justifications
for the reasons we've described
obviously the great benefit comes from
having the keys outside of google
and so yes while this is only uh well
there are some trade-offs
that are involved in choosing whether
you use external key manager
we think that for those very very
sensitive operations
those are the ones where you're going to
want to consider using key access
justifications as well
so what data is in scope for key access
justifications
generally speaking it's the high
sensitivity data so you can think about
it as things like the bigquery table
data
but not your bigquery query stream and
so you should read the documentation
when you're onboarded
and consider these things when you're
making the decision of
what information you want to architect
as part of this uh
this service
i'm now going to walk through a
demonstration that talks about
how you can set up key access
justifications and use it
uh with some of our partners
let's take a look at how i can use a
variety of external key management tools
to set blocking policy that uses key
access justifications
here i am using the talus tool to set
the set of allowed key access
justifications
and i'm going to try and do the same
thing with the tool by photonics
i'm also going to try and do the same
thing using the ionic tool which i'll
continue using for the rest of the
purposes of this demonstration
as you can see any partner that supports
the use of key access justifications
will allow you to use these
justifications to gate access to your
keys
based on the inbound requests that
contain those justifications
let's go ahead and use the example of
running a query using bigquery
with a table that's encrypted by an
externally managed key
i press the run button and the query is
successful and when i go to my external
key manager i can see why
the customer initiated access value was
used to decrypt my
my table and because i've allowed that
value
the query was successful later on in the
day
i'm going to go ahead and check my
external key manager again
here i can see that a new decryption
request has been granted
this time for a google initiated system
operation because bigquery needed to do
this in order to compress my data and
perform further optimizations
now if i were to have an issue where i
needed to contact google support
and google support needed to make an
access to my data
they would need to use this tool which
validates the justification or validates
the case number that i've opened to see
whether they should have access
when they go ahead and press the send
button here you'll see that the access
gets denied
if i go back to my external key manager
page i can see that a request was made
with customer initiated support as the
reason
but because i'm denying that value they
were unable to make that access
i actually do need to give them access
though because i really need them to
check this out
so i'm going to go ahead and delete that
customer initiated support value from
the deny statement
if the administrator tries to make the
access now again using the same support
case number
it will be validated first on our side
checking whether that case is a real
case and whether it's open and assigned
to the person in question
and whether the administrator has the
appropriate privileges but then it's
also evaluated again by the key manager
and this time it's allowed and i can see
the customer initiated support here in
the values column
so hopefully you got a better
understanding of how key access
justifications and external key manager
work together in practice
to make you the ultimate arbiter of
access to your data and why that's such
an important thing to have when you're
putting
very very highly sensitive information
on the cloud
what are some of the key takeaways we
want you to leave with this presentation
the first of all is keep your data in
our cloud
not your keys you're going to get this
unprecedented level of control
and keep possession of your keys use
projected data
using the external key manager to store
them outside of gcp
we also have an upcoming cloud ecamm
white paper that you should look out for
it's going to talk about some best
practices on how to architect the cloud
ekm with gcp
so that you can take into account some
of the reliability concerns you might
have
then if possible you should use key
access justifications to get you that
extra amount of granularity of and
visibility over access to your data
through the use of these key access
policies and when you store your keys
outside of gcp you can set these
policies up to deny google access for
whatever reason so you can continue
using your service as you were
beforehand
while knowing that you're in control and
having the ability to block google for
reasons that you don't want
we hope you've really gotten a lot out
of this presentation today and we're
extremely excited to continue talking to
you about these new products
as we continue to expand our offerings
in this space thanks very much and we
look forward to hearing from you soon
bye